pour le professeur arnaud des linges et
une page se tourne pendant deux ans il a
porté le combat des cardiologues
chalonnais pour l'ouverture d'un service
d'angioplastie complément naturel et
indispensable de l'unité de cardiologie
il l'a porté en tant que chef du service
de cardiologie et aussi comme présidente
de la commission médicale
d'établissement cela avec le soutien de
tous les élus du chalonnais mais pour
lui la dernière rencontre avec la rs l'a
convaincu que la concertation est au
point mort j'ai vu une rs extrêmement
fermement bloquée dans sa position j'en
ai conclu que face à sète
cette violence oui la position la plus
adaptée pour moi maintenant était de me
retirer en souplesse et de laisser le la
communauté médicale sous la conduite
d'un nouveau président de cme poursuivre
le combat
figure emblématique et respect c'est
arnaud des linges et continuera le
combat en tant que médecin mais les deux
années écoulées lui laisse un sentiment
amer je trouve que c'est un immense
gâchis
la réalité est têtue
les faits sont têtus le besoin persiste
et il faudra bien que la rs d'antan d'un
jour l'attitude de la rs et le grand
mystère de ce dossier après la
reconnaissance du besoin d'angioplastie
à chalon juillet 2016
elle n'a cessé ensuite de durcir sa
position au point de fixer à chalon des
critères désormais inatteignable pour
accéder à sa demande le professeur des
linges et comme d'autres aimeraient
beaucoup connaître les raisons d'une
telle attitude